[Musik]
das tagesgespräch war phoenix heute mit
jürgen hardt den außenpolitischen
sprecher der unionsfraktion im bundestag
grüße sie ganz herzlich jetzt haben wir
die urteilsverkündung gezeigt wir
wollten eigentlich auch den protest noch
zeigen
reden wir erst mal über das urteil
pervers wird gesagt dazu zynisch was
sagen sie
ich kann das nur bestätigen und sehe das
genauso wie annegret kramp-karrenbauer
das ursprüngliche urteil das ja zur
bewährung ausgesetzt war und das jetzt
wegen angeblichen verstoßes gegen
bewährungsauflagen in eine haftstrafe
umgewandelt wird ist ja vom europäischen
menschenrechtsgerichtshof als
politisches fehlurteil gewertet worden
in der wahlen hat im übrigen auch einen
schadensersatz zugesprochen bekommen
damals ging es darum ihn daran zu
hindern für die präsidentschaftswahlen
2018 zu kandidieren
denn wer im gefängnis sitzt kann in
russland nicht kandidieren und das was
jetzt geschieht dient meines erachtens
dazu ihn daran zu hindern bei den
dumawahlen also bei den parlamentswahlen
im september entweder persönlich oder
wird als führer einer starken politische
gruppe anzutreten
das ist undemokratisch hoch drei das
zeigt in welche kleptokratie und
diktatur russland leider unter polizei
klein ist ja fernab der
rechtsstaatlichkeit formuliert die
bundeskanzlerin
wie viele rechtsstaat gibt es denn also
angemessen an diesem beispiel jetzt das
ja nun für furore sorgt und auch für
viele proteste sorgt nicht nur im lande
selbst sondern eben auch im ausland was
zeigt dass für ein russland das problem
russlands ist dass der präsident und
seine führungseliten diesem land in den
letzten jahrzehnten nichts gutes getan
haben sie haben zwar höhere öl- und
gaseinnahmen gehabt aber sie haben
dieses geld nicht investiert in
infrastruktur in wissenschaft in
diversifizierung der industrie sondern
sie haben damit die freunde des
präsidenten zu deren gemacht das ist ein
der kleptokratie auch im übrigen der
mensch der sich jetzt als diejenige zu
erkennen gibt dem angeblich dieser
palast gehört derweil die putin
zuschreibt ist ja derjenige der
milliarden- wir wollen verdient hat
dadurch dass auch zu überhöhten preisen
staatsaufträge absolviert hat das land
wird von dieser rasmussen und
rachsüchtigen clique im kreis
ausgebeutet und die menschen merken dass
sie merken dass in ihrem land die dinge
nicht vorangehen dass russland lässt
sich zurück bleibt im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert gegenüber anderen staaten
und dass die herrscher reicher werden
und das ist eine ausgesprochen brenzlige
situation und ich kann nur hoffen dass
die menschen die kraft haben friedlicher
weise ihren protest zu artikulieren und
dass die parlamentswahlen im september
tatsächlich durch den druck der straße
einigermaßen gerecht ablaufen im
augenblick sieht es allerdings nicht
danach aus er hat also was unsere
korrespondenten auch berichten ist dass
das natürlich demonstrationen sind die
das land verteilt stattfinden aber dass
es nicht die mehrheit ist vladimir putin
kann schon noch auf eine mehrheit hoffen
und zählen in seinem land die hinter ihm
stehen egal was da in moskau passiert im
kreml passiert das ist ja schon ein
zustand wo wir uns fragen müssen okay
wer kann herrn putin überhaupt
irgendetwas könnten wir im westen etwas
tun stichwort beispielsweise nord stream
2 erstens glaube ich dass die am besten
einfach auch dafür sorgen können dass
die geschehnisse und russland
transparent werden die medien in
russland sind zum großen teil
gleichgeschaltet das internet wird
zunehmend eingeschränkt das war ja
eigentlich immer ein punkt in den
letzten jahren dass wir gesagt haben es
gibt unterdrückte presse in russland
aber die sozialen netzwerke das internet
ist einigermaßen paar ja auch da werden
die zügel angezogen
ich glaube dass wir diese transparenz
herstellen müssen damit die russischen
bürgerinnen und bürger auf ihren wegen
der doch die wahrheit über die
politischen geschehnisse wandel der
zeiten natürlich die frage beantworten
müssen wie abhängig wollen wir
wirtschaftlich speziell in der
energieversorgung von russland sein wie
viel gas ist in europäischen gasnetzen
aus russland akzeptabel ohne dass dazu
ein so ganz abschied wert herr hat oder
spät die pipeline eine rolle
ja er hat was weißt wollen wir sind
abhängig und dann kommt noch die
pipeline oder ich glaube dass wir im
augenblick nicht abhängig sind
speziell deutschland hat einen anteil
von rund 40 prozent russischen gas in
den leitungen an der eu staaten haben
deutlich weniger
es gibt auch verschiedene zuleitungen es
gibt auch weitere möglichkeiten das aus
osteuropa
aus zentralasien oder eben auch aus dem
europäischen raum zu holen wir bauen
flüssiggasterminals ich glaube eine
diversifizierung der energieversorgung
ist im vollen gange
diese bleiben dort treten aus dem 2 da
gibt es ja viele die auch sagen die wird
gar nicht gebraucht weil wir ja in
europa insgesamt weg von fossilen
energieträgern
ich glaube die pipeline selbst ist zwar
zum symbol geworden ob die entscheidende
frage ist wo ziehen wir die grenze und
ob das russische gas jetzt bei ähnlicher
fall bleibt oder moz trotzdem eins oder
zwei zu uns kommt in der nichts an der
tatsache dass russisches gas ist und
deswegen müssen wir bei russisches gas
reden und dann die frage der pipeline
entscheiden im nachgang dazu haben sie
eine haltung zur pipeline
ich glaube dass das projekt
wirtschaftlich unsinnig es ich glaube
dass diejenigen die im vertrauen auch
die lockeren sprüche von früheren
bundeskanzler schröder und putin in
dieses projekt investiert haben ihr geld
in den sand setzen werden und ich finde
es ein treppenwitz wenn wir jetzt
deutlicher seit diese pipeline verbieten
unter umständen sogar schadensersatz
wichtig wären gegenüber den unternehmen
und sie damit auf schlanke weise aus der
wirtschaftlichen verantwortung ausgeben
ich glaube dass wir deswegen das
augenmerk gar nicht so sehr auf diese
leitung richten sollten
ich glaube dass es zwischen innerhalb
europas und mit nordamerika in den
nächsten wochen allerdings intensive
gespräche geben wird wie man im wege
einer einvernehmlichen lösung die
energie sicherheitsfragen auch
interessen amerikaner anderer europäer
rücksicht mit diesem mit dieser pakt
irgendwer ohne dass wir jetzt gesetzlich
ein baustopp verhängt
da setze ich darauf dass wir im weißen
haus auch eine neue offenheit und
gesprächsbereitschaft haben das muss man
noch abwarten wie deutlich man da wird
da gibt's franzosen die werden
deutlicher aber nochmal jetzt zurück zum
ausgangspunkt
navalny wird jetzt ins gefängnis
gesteckt journalisten internationale
journalisten werden verhaftet in
russland und dann stellt sich ein
außenminister hin und sagt wir wollen
erstmal beweise haben dafür dass wir
herrn avanti vergiftet haben so und
kriegen wenn ich meine irgendwann ist
doch auch mal ende der fahnenstange und
der geduld oder also ganz konkret was
die vergiftung derweil die es angeht
verstößt ausland ja gegen die pflichten
zur zusammenarbeit mit der spö waffen
oder die das verbot von chemischen
waffen überwacht und deswegen ist auch
russland mit sanktionen belegt die
personen die dafür verantwortlich sind
sind mit sanktionen belegt wir sind auch
richtig und europäisch einheitlich ich
glaube das ist auch die richtige antwort
im blick auf die
völkerrechtsverletzungen russlands auf
der krim und den daraus die ukraine im
blick auf die innenpolitische situation
des landes müssen wir sehr genau abwägen
ob wir mit konkreten sanktionen die sich
nicht nur gegen personen sondern
vielleicht auch wirtschaftlicher art zu
errichten nicht putin munition gehen
weiter gegen uns zu polemisieren und zu
setzen denn in seinem land ist die
meinung der öffentliche meinung zu
europa ja gut ein gut teil manipuliert
weil tatsächlich kein wahrhaftiges bild
da ist und wenn zum beispiel in russland
im augenblick obst frisches obst und
gemüse etwas früher aus polen zum
beispiel importiert wurde
da sagt putin das liegt an den
sanktionen des westens in wirklichkeit
sind es die gegenmaßnahmen die er gegen
unsere sanktionen weg der können
verhängt hat nämlich ein paar sprachen
für solches obst und gemüse aber wir
haben ja nicht die möglichkeit den
russischen bürgerinnen bürgern das 1 1
so zu erklären und deswegen müssen wir
schon aufpassen ob wir mit den
sanktionen tatsächlich die richtigen
treffen mein favorit sind personen
sanktionen weil die ganzen oligarchen im
umfeld potenziale ihr geldlichen
russland haben ihre freizeit auch nicht
in russland verbringen sondern in paris
rom london und sofort wird sie dort
erleben dass ihre kreditkarte nicht mehr
funktionieren dass ihre konten gesperrt
sind dann kann ich mir vorstellen wird
es auch druck auf putin geben etwas zu
ändern am ende muss natürlich jetzt die
chance genutzt werden bei den dumawahlen
zumindest ein klares politisches zeichen
zu setzen dass putin und seine partei in
russland nicht ein und alles sind sagt
jürgen hardt der außenpolitische
sprecher der unionsfraktion im bundestag
ganz herzlichen dank für das gespräch
auf wiedersehen